you spoke about this last night in
relation to relationships and you said
that when you commit to somebody there
is the uh
inevitable pain
that any future catastrophe is going to
need to be worked out in a difficult way
between you and the person that you've
committed to as opposed to you being
able to go oh well cool i'm out of here
the side chicks are warm on tinder in
any case i'm off yeah right right right
well that was something i really learned
from reading carl jung he thought about
marriage as
he used alchemical symbolism as
purification
requires heat
heat and pressure
and so you have a container and it gets
hot and that's when you want to leave
that's when the changes can take place
and sometimes they have to be radical to
maintain the relationship
very radical but hopefully those radical
changes are positive but what makes you
think you'd make them if there wasn't a
fire lit under you and one of the fires
is i can't escape from you
here we are locked in combat right here
we are in this adversarial relationship
beneficial advocacy yeah exactly
beneficial adversary yeah there's no out
except through
and there's no evidence that through
will work
but
and so that's part of the utility of the
vow is to turn the temperature up
and you know you could say well i'll
escape but the problem with that
is escape to where
you're not going to have another
relationship and if to the degree that
you brought the catastrophe to the
previous relationship which is at least
a 50 50 probability right
what makes you think you're not going to
bring it to the next relationship you're
the common denominator between all of
the experts right i've had i've had many
bad relationships like
really
i've never met anyone i can trust
okay
everyone's motivated by power
what's the common denominator here
exactly
so
you know it's tricky because i've
i mean lots of people in my family have
been divorced which is the case in
virtually every family and i don't feel
like i'm in a position to shake my
finger at people and say
you know you failed
and with more effort you could have
succeeded
that's not up to me to decide
and many of those people have gone on to
have more successful relationships
the second time around
but
that doesn't belie the initial point and
besides even the people
who went through a divorce wanted to get
married again they still see utility in
the vow and the container
so you know
you can't make these things into
inviolable absolutes zero divorce zero
drugs zero climate change
no
that's that isn't how the world works
partly because there's always the snake
in the garden right there's no zero
not without the application of
increasingly totalitarian force
it has to be some leeway but you don't
blow the whole systems apart just to
provide some leeway it's a very
difficult thing to negotiate
you know i've had clients who had
partners that
really couldn't be negotiated with
the whole idea of negotiation wasn't
negotiable
and i didn't see they really had any
choice to either
maintain the millstone around their neck
and drown
or to leave
it's an awful choice but that doesn't
mean that marriage is a prison that no
one should ever enter
it just means that things are
complicated what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace